[Music]
[Applause]
the big story from last night Aaron
judge hit his 61st home run in Toronto
and a lot of people came out hoping they
could catch that souvenir Matt Bushman
is the one who picked the ball up in the
bullpen he's the Blue Jays Bullpen coach
and he joins us along with his wife
Sarah Walsh who covers the Buccaneers
for the NFL Network so uh Matt let me
start with you and what kind of strategy
did you have in the bullpen if that home
run ball ended up there
uh well we had we didn't have much of a
strategy unfortunately because I caught
it and uh and then just flipped it uh to
David Howell another coach of ours in
the bullpen
um who then proceeded to panic a little
bit and then we all just kind of stood
and stared at each other thinking what
are we gonna do
okay was there any thought of what's
this worth and do I want to hold on to
this
well
um we talked about it I know that the 62
was the one that uh people had talked
about being worth a lot of money but um
yeah we had talked about maybe having
someone hidden in the hallway behind us
and you just flip it to him then he just
runs right out of the stadium and then
we make sure we talk to him later
um trying to split it between uh the
guys with the pen but when it happened
uh I think we just we grabbed it and I
didn't want to throw it back up in the
stands that's that's one thing I didn't
want to do did you think about asking
judge for anything
even though you're on the on the Blue
Jays
um yeah I think we're gonna try to work
something out uh Zach Britain came over
from the other Bullpen and so we'll have
to work something out even if it's just
him not uh signing back anywhere in the
AL East unless
if he promises to go to the San
Francisco Giants then you're fine
perfect that's great
um your lovely wife Sarah Walsh covers
the Buccaneers for the NFL Network she's
down in Florida she's dealing with all
of the uh the elements there at what
point do you hear from your wife that
you've just given up this valuable
baseball
well as soon as I walked in after the
game
I heard about four different people say
did you see what your wife tweeted and I
said oh this will be good I'm sure I'm
sure it'll be uh it'll be pretty funny
and it was so
um I thought I'd have a lot immediately
when I caught it I knew that uh Twitter
would probably go crazy and then lo and
behold my wife was part of that well
let's bring in Sarah Sarah thank you for
joining us hopefully uh the family's uh
safe there outside of Tampa were you
watching the game
and it's Wednesday night and that is a
big night in my household for the
Beverly Hills housewives so I was
incredibly busy finding out how the
Aspen vacation that went awry went down
um I am very fortunate I do not have
power I lost power at my house I had to
evacuate I live on Clearwater Beach
actually so I'm in my childhood home I'm
with my parents and I I was like
everyone needs to get out of the room
the housewives are on I have
five-year-old twins people are losing
their mind and then my phone started
blowing up my dad actually who's a huge
race fan was flipping between the Rays
and the Jays and it had been a
discussion in our house my mom even was
on top of like can you believe what
these seats are going for to catch this
Aaron judge ball and then let's start
phone started blowing up and I'm like oh
my god did he catch this and
um but like to just set the scene
because I can't see you guys like this
is like this is such like typical of our
life Matt is is zooming into you on a
golf course and I am stuck in a
hurricane with our twin so like this is
our life so I like I don't have power
Mac's golfing that's out like living the
dream like I'm trying to figure out how
life is existing down here so
give them some stuff I gave him some
Twitter did I think it was gonna blow up
the way it did um and and in all
seriousness I knew he would not keep
that ball like and so people were you
know then people you know how Twitter is
right but like there's no way he's going
to keep that ball he also like we've had
this conversation before like when I've
worked at previous places and there's
been situations like this and I'm always
like give it to the guy that hit it like
I mean we we know that like intuitively
like that would just be our situation
but was I gonna give him grief about it
like of course I am like I mean what and
then he shows no emotion which I I knew
like he's just you know we've got to
play it safe so then I'm like the wife
out there that's like saying stuff and
um basically stealing his moment so um
it's kind of par for the course
uh are you in trouble at all Matt
ERS with my wife yeah yes okay yeah well
that was the other part of the
discussion and the bullpen was hey we
want to play golf tomorrow but you know
a couple guys have people in Florida and
we said
like if it's real bad do you do you play
golf do you go out and play golf and so
you know you're working through that I
think it was trying to figure out what
level is it okay to go out and play golf
uh
yeah
I can see they're golfing Sarah can't
see the look on your face like you you
know you're in trouble and there's
probably going to be a follow-up
conversation when we end this
conversation
oh yeah I'm just going to my Stock's
going way down
Dan when this season ends
and responsible for our kids anymore I'm
like I'm not getting off the cat like I
mean things are really Gonna Change when
it's baseball season ends wow are you uh
do you know what your uh location is
going to be with the Buccaneers game
against Kansas City
uh so I believe the Buccaneers are going
to play that game
um I believe they're going to play it
here in Tampa okay
um I actually won't be there because I'm
flying hopefully to New York to host
good morning football early next week so
this has been uh it's been like a crazy
roll and we to be honest the Bucks are
down in Miami now
um so I'll be they've been zooming with
us with the the folks that cover the
team so I'll be on a call with them
Brady speaking a little later today uh
and I think that they're gonna play that
game here in Tampa Tampa was really
fortunate In This Storm and that being
said there's a lot of people here
without power and there's a lot of trees
and things down and it's still going on
I mean it's gusting outside the windows
right now but compared to
um our friends and family in Fort Myers
it's it's nowhere near close to the
devastation that they are currently
dealing with
uh Sarah great to talk to you Matt if
you would somehow have gotten 62 not 61.
would you have kept 62.
I mean I think there was more of a
discussion around that yeah we you know
it may have been uh naughty quick
handoff let's just let's just say that
well more importantly good luck with the
conversation that's going to happen
after this conversation is over
yeah that's the most important one
that's the one but it's going to be
tough but we'll get through it we'll
work through it and good luck with your
golf game today
thank you yeah at the very least
uh that's Matt Bushman and uh Sarah
Walsh the Blue Jays Bullpen coach and
Sarah covers the Buccaneers for the NFL
Network you're going to see the look on
his face it's like
God am I in trouble